التصريحات حول كيفيه التعامل النساء مع
زواجها ودعوتهن الاحترام والشيء من الخضوع
اقله بالكلام دائما تثير الجدل هذا المنح
عادته مؤخرا تصريحات الاعلاميه المصريه
ياسمين العز تصريحات تثير جدلا واسعا في
مصر ما يجعل الاعلاميه شابه تنجح في تصدر
تراند على محركات البحث من هذه المواضيع
التي اثارت الجدل والنقد مؤخرا مجموعه من
النصائح للزوجات في كيفيه التعامل مع
الازواج كوضع القاب لزوجها اثناء نداءه
وعن ترك مساحه اكبر للرجل في خزانه
الملابس وتحدثت ايضا عن معاناه الزوج عند
خروجه مع زوجته للتسوق فاجات المشاهدين
بتصريح يقول ان تصرفات الرجال مع النساء
هي من روح الفرعون الزميل لدى حجازي نزلت
الى الشارع واجرت تجربه اجتماعيه وسالت
الناس عن رايهم في مضمون كلام ياسمين
العزه
جدل كبير حول تصريحات ياسمين عز واراها في
العلاقه بين الرجل والمراه اللي بتنادي
على جوزك كده يا محمد حازم مثلا
قولي لجوزك يا استاذ محمد
يا استاذ محمد تحب تشرب ايه اكيد شفت
تصريحات الاخيره لياسمين عزت رايك ايه بقى
في الموضوع ده طبعا هي غلط لان هي متحركه
الرجاله على الستات وده غلط اصلا احنا
برده لنا ان احنا المفروض بقى لنا راينا
حاجه في المجتمع مش مش لازم يعني هو
يمشينا هو يحترمني وانا هاحترمه
اوفر شويه
اوفر في ايه دي دي دي ست نصفاكم طول الوقت
[موسيقى]
زياده عن اللزوم يعني اللي هو الطبيعي مش
كده يا استاذ محمد
استاذه وانت تقوليها يا استاذه ان هو احنا
متجوزين بقى عشان نحطه على القاب هاعمل
جوزها محطتين يعني
انا ست حجه وعارف ربنا
يرضي الله يمشي مع جوزه على الحلوه والمره
صح ولا لا
شويه بس اهو يعني
طبعا الست تفكر الراجل وتحترم الراجل
وبرده الراجل يحترم الست طول ما هم
محترمين بعضهم يا بنتي هيبقوا كويسين
[موسيقى]
خالص
ينضم الينا من القاهره للكاتب احمد عبده
والخاطبه عبير حسن اهلا بكم احمد وعبير في
دقيقه اول شيء نسمع موقفكم اذا كنتم مع
اود احمد ابدى معاك هل انت مع تفخيم تمجيد
تعظيم الى درجه الخضوع للزوج حتى يرضى عن
زوجته
[موسيقى]
في
ست كبيره حتى ديت يعني قالت ان انا كنت
عايز اقول له ان الاحترام متبادل ما فيش
حاجه ما فيش احترام من ناحيه واحده
الاحترام متبادل ما بين الشخصين فلو
الدنيا هتمشي ان انا اقول لامراتي يا
استاذه استاذ فده مش منطقي احنا كده مش
متجوزين في سنتر يعني ههه لكن انا شايف
التصريحات همم اوفر جدا هي مجرد مثيره
للجدل التصريحات ديت ما فيش تصريحات
بالشكل دوت ما فيش علاقه زوجيه محترمه
هتكون بالشكل دوت خالص
تخيل الامور الوصل
لمرحله همم يدوس بالجزمه على السجاده عادي
بقى طبعا ما فيش الكلام ده يعني
هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
انا طبعا مع الاستاذ ياسمين ياسمين عز ايه
فراشه الاعلام المذيعه الجميله الخلوقه
اللي افكارها كلها
للاسره اللي بتاكد دائما على القيم
الجميله اللي تربينا عليها مع اهالينا هو
ده كلام امهاتنا هو دوت كلام قرايبنا هو
دوت كلام اخواتنا الكبار علشان نعمر
بيوتنا ونستمر في علاقه زوجيه سعيده
اساسها الاحترام المتبادل انا شايفه انها
ما قالتش حاجه جديده تستدعي مننا الهجوم
عليها بل بالعكس كل افكارها بتدعوا
للترابط الاسري والسعاده الزوجيه واحترام
الاخ واحترام الراجل وكينونه الرجل طيب
المفارقه يا احمد انه انت همم ضد وعبير
معه كمان في الاستديو في معوض انا يعني
انا مع الحب والتقدير بدون تحاليل بدون
تمثيل قدر زوجي من دون امثل عليه
احمد اا انه استاذ احمد ما ما الاعتراض
اذا اذا كانت المراه همم تقدر زوجها
وتحترم وحتى بل يعني تقول لا من الالفاظ
ما تعطي مكان حتى كلمه السيد او لقب سي
السيد همم ابو العيال الى اخره من هذه
الالقاب شنو الغلط انا انك تستخدم المراه
استاذ
انا قلت خير الامور الوسط انا مش لازم
عشان مراتي تحترمني تقول لي يا استاذ يعني
ده مش المنطق بيقول ان انا اول دي مدرس
انا والدتي عمرها قالت له يا استاذ محمد
عادي ههه هي عمري ما بيكون هي عادي ما
تقولش
مش عادي انها تقول لزوجها يا استاذ تقول
له ازاي يا استاذ
تقول له في البيت يا استاذ هتقول له يا
استاذ
طيب
ايش رايك في هذا اجتماع كمان
[موسيقى]
ههه لا طبعا مش لازم الكولاجين ناخذه عن
طريق الضرب بصراحه ههه انا مع ضد ضد العنف
ضد المراه تماما تماما تماما انما انا مع
احترام الطرفين كلاهما لبعض بطريقه تبيننا
قدام اولادنا وانا كسبت متزوجه من حوالي
24 سنه انا ماشيه بالمنهج اللي بتقول عليه
الاستاذ ياسمين الاحترام والود المتبادل
علشان نخلق حتى جيل متربي على اسس علميه
ونفسيه سليمه بيسودها جو من الاحترام ما
بين الطرفين عشان الاسره تستقر طيب انا
كسبت عبيره تفضل احنا قدوه لاولادنا قبل
ما نكون قبل ما نكون قدوه للي حوالينا
خلينا نروح للاستاذ احمد بانه استاذ احمد
دلوقت همم بيزعجك كذا اذا المراه طبعا
اكيد الضرب مش مقبول باي حال من الاحوال
لكن المراه حينما همم تد زوجها او تقول لك
كلام جميل او حتى كلام من من قبيل
الاحترام امام الاخرين وحتى بينه وبينه هل
هذا مرفوض مش مقبول
[موسيقى]
في الجيل الحال الاحترام بيننا وبين يعني
بص هاقول لك حاجه يا استاذ الاحترام بيننا
وبين بعض قدام الناس ده جميل جدا ومطلوب
وواجب لكن الاحترام اللي هي تقول لي يا
استاذ احمد واحنا في البيت دوت انا مش
شايف ان دوت بيدل على الاحترام الاحترام
في حاجات كثير جدا بتعبر عنه بالاسلوب
بالتعامل بالود بالنقاش باحترام الراي
الاخر هو دوت الاحترام بالنسبه لي لكن انا
مراتي تقول لي يا استاذ فهل هي كده
بتحترمني واحنا في البيت تقول لي يا استاذ
الواحد يعني هي ما ما اقول حاجه يا بيبي
مش عشان تقول له استاذ في البيت يعني
هي عبير
منطقي جدا منطقي جدا ان الزوجه تطيع زوجها
تطيع عمياء تطيع لكن هل تتحدث معه
وتتحدث معه الا باذنه ولازم اذا سر الى
نظر اليها سرته وتسمع كلامه وتطيعه وتكون
تحت امره وتتشاور معه وتاخذ رايه في
الكبيره وفي الصغيره وتغسل له رجليه وتهتم
بنظافته الشخصيه وتهتموا ببيته وتهتم
باولاده وتحترمه ما بينها وما بينه ما فيش
دلوقتي بره البيت وبيكون جوه البيت
مقطع من التصريحات ونرجع لكبير واحمد
ليه بتنادي على جوزك بدون ارقام
الزوج اللي درسنا كلنا زمان فين الدرس ده
الموضوع ده فكروني نعمل حلقه بعنوان تفخيم
الزوج
نسيتي افكرك كبير
مثلا
قولي لجوزك يا استاذ محمد
يا استاذ محمد تحب تشرب ايه
اسمعي مني تكسبك لو جوزك اسمه محمد قولي
له باللقب ده يا استاذ محمد
طيب يعني عبير يعني الواحده بتعتبر زوجها
حبيبها ونصفها الثاني تحترموا وتقدروا هل
يمكن ان تعتبروا فرعون صغير
المقصود المقصود من كلمه فرعون صغير اييه
هي تفخيم الزوج واعتباره حاجه وقيمه كبيره
جدا جدا في حياتنا وما نسالهاش الكلمه
اللي هي قالتها برده ان الزوج احد النعم
من ربنا علينا فعلا الزوج نعمه كبيره جدا
جدا على زوجته بخصوصا لما يكون زوج صالح
واب صالح لاولاده بيقوم على رعايه بيته
وبيهتم بكل تفاصيله همم انا شايفه ان
الكلام بتاعها هو كلام مستساخ جدا جدا
وكلنا مع ال- راي بتاعها اكيد
بعيدا بعيدا عن همم يعني استاذ احمد همم
خليه ياخذ الجانب الاخر قبل قليل ااه يعني
سهام من فقدت انه المراه همم
يعني انا دلوقتي مثلا حضرتك من ضمن
التصريحات تغسل رجله لما تروح وهو يروح
احنا دلوقتي الدنيا غير الاول تمام
يعني دلوقتي الست بتشتغل في ستات بتشتغل
12 ساعه وفي ستات بتشتغل 24 ساعه لو
دكتوره انا بعد ما تخلص يوم ده كله ومروحه
مش قادره تقف اقول لها تعالي رجلي ده فين
المنطق كده يعني بقى يا سيدي ما تغسل له
رجليه تعمل له باديكير ماني كثير صح هذه
نفسها هي نفسها ولا تختلف
يروح بيوتي سنتر يعني هي حابه تعمل له اذا
كان برضاها وحبا منها نرفضه ليه احنا
مجتمعنا
طيب هي هي حابه تعمل هي حبه تعمل لجوزها
احنا بنعترض ليه لو هي حابه تعمل لو هي
حابه تعمل لكن انا ما اطلعش على الميديا
اقول تعمل ده عبير ايه رايك
الزوجه هي الزوجه كانت طبيبه كانت دكتوره
كانت وزيره كانت رئيسه وزراء الزوجه هي
الزوجه المهم بتاعتها ما بتتقسمش والمهام
بتاعتها ما بنغفلش بجانب عن جانب وما
بيجيش على بيتنا وزوجنا على حساب شغلنا لو
هي مش قادره توفق ما بين الاثنين يبقى
تقعد في بيتها بيتها اولى بها وجوزها
واسرتها اولى بها مهمه الست الرئيسيه في
الحياه هي الزوج والاسره والاولاد
والتربيه
مش مهمتها انها تشتغل وتجيب فلوس لان ديت
مهمه الزوج ولو هناخذ باعتبار ان ممكن اي
حد يغسل له يديه زي ما حد رجليه زي ما
حضرتك بتقول كده فالبيوتي سنتر موجود
والكوافيرات موجودين والاماكن اللي موجوده
ومتوفره انما مهمه الزوجه اتجاه زوجها ما
حدش ثاني هيقوم بها غيرها هي بس ولو هو حس
منها عدم الاهتمام وعدم الرغبه في التواصل
معه بالشكل اللي هو يرتديه اكيد هيتجوز
عليها لان دوت برده حلال ربنا والراجل له
ان هو يتجوز مثنى وثلاث ورباع والست اللي
تريحه هو اللي هيعيش معها بقيه عمره مش
هيضطر واحده ابدا
[موسيقى]
بتقول حلال ربنا ان هو يتزوج عليها مع
حلال ربنا برده ان هو يعملها كويس ان هو
يحترمها ما هي الست ديت لو نزلت تشتغل
بتشتغل ليه مش عشان عيب مستوى افضل
لاولادها عشان مستوى افضل لبيتها ما هي
الحياه تعاون يا جماعه ما هي الحياه عمرها
ما بتمشي على لاين واحد دلوقتي غير زمان
زمان
عنده محل عطاره بيقف قدامه امين قاعده في
البيت لو نزلت
على زوجته
والدتي بتحترم والدي احترام مبالغ فيه
عمرها ما ما ما غسلت رجله ولا الجو ده
والاحترام والتقدير اساس كل العالم
بتلك الامور خالص
بعبير حسن اشكركم احمد وعبير